[Music]
in bitch-slap news flapping beatbox
I think slapping someone is more
satisfying than punching agreed because
when you punch you kind of get hurt a
little yeah it hurts yeah it is sass but
when you slap oh yeah you feel so good
yeah yeah I wanna hear what he's
wonderful
we haven't even read the title submitted
by Karla binges jkn a man was jailed for
slapping a teacher who punished him too
hard
20 years ago whoa 20 years worthy you do
get jailed yeah was it like hit
discipline back oh no this is also in
Asia oh you could get jailed for
slapping at Asia no no I'm saying it's
like this happened in Asia so they're
probably still slapping now in Japan
they stop doing it teachers but this guy
got jailed for slapping I want to hear
the story it seems like you know the
story that started all I know but I want
to hear her no one else knows yeah so
far I almost called you Joe I'm sorry
Jana gates no I'm not reading them
anymore just he got in trouble for radio
in central China she was sentenced to 18
months in prison after you got revenge
on his former teacher who would beat him
in class beat him up the video that went
over that let him you darling I didn't
see the video
please exactly we've seen this
have seen this we have seen this
yes so sad [ __ ] your mom is it I'm sorry
so [ __ ] your mom did you remember me
yeah you probably beat a lot of kids up
is I do you remember me he was like into
the guys that I'm sorry me as I [ __ ]
your mom yeah honestly just kept saying
the same thing yeah these tips in do you
remember me [ __ ] your mom and then you
and do you remember that you beat the
[ __ ] out of me I kind of stuff mmm yeah
[ __ ] that guy
which guy the young guy are the lads no
the one that [ __ ] was slapping little
kids little [ __ ] I don't like that
dude did he seek out what's the time
back then though 20 years ago a long
time 20 years is not a long time I think
we were in high school 20 years really
year 2000 so statute of limitations and
the u.s. suspect is seven years right I
think it's more about him reliving that
moment so in that moment what I see is
him slapping the person that just lapped
up yesterday in his head traumatized
yeah you could clearly tell this guy
didn't let go
so he's reliving that beating non-stop
yeah and then he's like oh I saw him and
it's fresh cuz that anger is like oh
dude that's some revenge [ __ ] right
there yeah well hopefully it stops the
teacher from eating kids you probably
retired Arnie yeah like for me it's so
like I hate this situation because I can
be in both people's shoes and I can
empathize for both people so
the guy that's slapping I can buy
[ __ ] I remember all the teachers
I [ __ ] hated yeah at that time when I
was that kid I wanted to beat the [ __ ]
out of not now when they're old and
helpless and I'm Way stronger and bigger
not now like I would want I wanted to be
dead like if we could time travel back
in time I'll beat the [ __ ] out of when
they're 30 so yeah so I can put my
helpless when they were yeah I could put
myself in that guy's shoes okay yeah
when they're all old and you look at
them you're like I can't do nothing man
if I put myself in the teachers shoes
I'm like [ __ ] every single teach
every single teacher at this school
smack the kids why are you taking it
personally I smack you I smacked him I
smacked her I smacked every single
person your mom thanked me gave me
apples after school for smacking you
because that's the culture like when
teachers smacked kids back in Asia the
parents apply thank you so much for
disciplining my kids during my off-duty
hours
hmm so I'm like and I put myself in that
situation on my wall it just sucks that
20 years later now you're the only one
that took it personally and now this
[ __ ] me up for so like I can put
myself in both situation this sucks
just sucks really bad and what if he was
just in a big-ass nuisance in class in
the class he could have been an extra
day I think that's what yeah yeah like
and then I forgave every you know
teacher that got annoyed by me cuz it's
like but you forgave that for getting
annoyed by you I forgive you I forgive
you it's okay make sense though I gotta
go right yeah yeah because they'll react
to their annoyance is what I'm saying
and it's a child you're supposed to be
the adult in between the two and not get
annoyed and handle the situation
appropriately but I also understand that
they're human there's oversized
classrooms there's crazy [ __ ] kids out
there and I was the I was a part of the
problem right so in any situation the
adult should always have the upper hand
but then we're all human so you know
they're gonna break right yeah so in
these cases I look back and I'm like
okay yeah I get it
it just happened yeah and in this case
it's he can't he can't forgive that he
can't realize that maybe this guy was
going through family problems maybe he
was going through so much stress of his
own
this kid was probably really problematic
and he just took out a lot of that rage
on that one kid this video happened in
June of last year so there's a
possibility you guys saw it but I
searched our channel and I don't think
we did a Dicky news on eBay anyway the
whole thing here though the reason why
it's news now is because he has been
sentenced to jail after the trial in
jail
he claimed that his middle school
teacher would punish him violently for
sleeping in class and that's why he just
like held off all this [ __ ] in but he
use a word violently - I don't know how
crazy it was she was probably crazy yeah
so he actually got his friend to film
this video and he posted it so because
of that Oh actually right justice is
served
yeah so because I guess found guilty of
quote picking quarrels and provoking
trouble cuz he set it up it wasn't like
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that fool like
he set the whole thing up so he didn't
get in trouble for assault he got in
trouble for [ __ ] for setting it up
funny it was also because they were
recording a video for a just
dissemination dissemination and so
they're saying that this attracted
several onlookers and raised public
concerns I had a severe impact on the
teacher and his family as well as
violating moral standards in public
order and so because of that his
behavior constitutes a crime and so
they're more worried about that shamed
enough is violent assault he ended up
ruining himself in and because that was
his first time offending they gave him a
more lenient punishment but online not
everyone is saying that the teacher
should be punished because as well
because of like what he did in his past
I wish there were more details like did
he single him out was he equal with all
the students yeah yes like what also
yeah was it just falling asleep it give
it was just falling asleep in class
- that's pretty it's so hard cuz like
from American mindset it's way different
so when I was a kid like my mom would
read these books on how to be a proper
student yeah so if you're falling asleep
in class as a student it's your
responsibility to carry a knife and stab
yourself to wake yourself up what so if
you understand
mindset it's like that's pretty extreme
even at Asian terms no but these are
like scriptures that my mom would have
me memorized that people didn't read
that they stopped reading back in like
1880s but this is like the UH because
your mom's [ __ ] I know but this book
it's also a basis of standard and at
least all taiwanese education at that
time you know so like just understanding
that mindset so open when you fall
asleep in class when when you can't take
responsibility for yourself and someone
else has to take the responsibility of
staying awake on top of them they can do
anything they want to you it's like that
type of mindset probably 23 years ago
whatever so I don't think America was
that far off because they used to
discipline kids they would paddle them
they would be you know and in Catholics
yeah for sure yeah yeah 20 years ago no
not 20 maybe yeah maybe 40 years ago yes
what just says uncle you just recently
passed he was 89 and I was talking to
him about how he grew up in Texas
and when he was uh he said a school kid
like his dad wasn't a minused teacher
administrator or whatever it was and he
goes if if kids were disrupting and
having problems are like arguing back
and forth they would just literally just
make them Duke it out and they're like
just fight or like whatever and they
would hit the kids and all that stuff so
I don't think it's really I think we're
just like kind of late to the game as
far as child development and stuff like
that but also in the great parable of
Batman revenge is not the way ya know it
gives no satisfaction yeah
even in Japan to my uncle what he says
that one of his teachers were [ __ ]
violent as hell and then he any he would
let any kids like he'll be like okay if
you if you have revenge or you want to
fight me we can go one-on-one I don't
care
and then so yeah cuz there a kid of
course he's gonna say that their high
school why your parents okay
nobody go through puberty were not five
no no no but in high school so after he
graduated him and his buddies jumped the
teacher yeah it wasn't one on one but
then he was like yeah and then he felt
like he deserved it no I mean she was
just it was just tough like he will just
fight huh for you just physically fight
so after they were done with that they
said like gone and then they would leave
cuz I
how the conversation went down but we
were talking about how kids today use
guns and knives and like their violence
and then they'll they'll come to school
and they'll stab their teachers and all
this stuff but he's like back in a day
like he was like thinking that maybe it
was better that you could just fight
because you could get it out of your
system you don't dive him right right
yeah but then he's like now it's like
overboard because people are shooting
and stabbing and all that stuff what
also sucks about teachers too is like a
lot of them forget that whoever they're
disciplining is gonna be an adult and
individually oh yeah they're just taking
that anger out right then and there but
this guy could be a doctor this guy
could be an engineer or be whoever like
later on and then they're just they just
see a little [ __ ] in front of them
without thinking how much they can scar
someone's future yeah yeah but I also
don't blame the teachers too because if
you think about it like they're not
trained well either because they're the
reason why people use violence and end
up beating others is because they don't
have a solution for what's happening and
they panic it comes out of them not
knowing what to do I know a lot of what
they should be teaching teachers is
viewed as like well that should be
taught at home but it's like you should
know because you're dealing with these
kids yeah parents will come into school
and they don't want other people
disciplining their kids or whatever
because I remember I got pinched by my
teachers oh I remember that yeah in
elementary school he's like I forgive
the pinch but but hopefully it's
something that good that comes from this
is you know they really kind of like to
modern times now because we have dad of
like what I'm traumatized is changing
yeah age is gonna change
[Music]